what i would conveyed in the statement
was that the national security team the
president met with this morning advised
the president and vice president that
another terror attack in kabul is likely
and they are taking maximum force
protection measures at the kabul airport
and in surrounding areas with our forces
as a result
i will note that the department of
defense also just gave a briefing this
morning and i will echo some of the
descriptions that they offered
the threat is ongoing and it is active
it is our troops are still in danger
that continues to be the case uh every
day that they are there uh most this is
the most dangerous part of the mission
this is the retrograde period of the
mission and what that means is that this
is the period of time when the military
commanders on the ground and forces
begin to move not just troops home but
also equipment home and that is
often a very uh dangerous part of any
mission but in this case they're also
doing that while there is a an ongoing
and acute threat from isis k
so that is what they are facing